so what was the real reason that Michael
Shanks AKA Daniel Jackson left Stargate
sg1 back in season five welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I would
like to apologize for my voice as I am
actually currently quite ill but I
thought I'd make this video because I
actually really want to talk about
Stargate I didn't make a video last week
and I've been dying to make content so
let's talk about why Michael Shanks who
played Daniel Jackson in Stargate sg1
why he left the show back in season five
why he felt that he wasn't being
utilized and why he felt that the
character wasn't really going anywhere
what are my thoughts on this let's get
into it Daniel Jackson is one of those
characters in a science fiction that
when he dies you know he's gonna return
at some point because he's died so many
times and every single time he's managed
to return now Stargate has a very unique
way of making this happen in the fact
that when Daniel Jackson died in season
5's Meridian after taking a lethal dose
of radiation he was actually helped to
ascend to a higher plane of existence
meaning his character still existed
within the universe and should it be the
case that Michael Shanks wanted to
return to Stargate sg1 they could easily
bring him back by basically descending
him from the higher plane back to the
Mortal plane and that's exactly what
happened in season five we saw Daniel
Jackson Ascend to the high plane of
existence after receiving a lethal dose
of radiation and then returned back to
the Mortal plane in season six now
during the time that Daniel was ascended
he was replaced by Jonas Quinn who
essentially took up the mantle of the
archaeologist of the team now I
personally really liked Jonas Quinn he
was a really really good character and I
actually I actually think it's quite sad
that because Michael Shanks decided to
return to Stargate Jonas Quinn the
character was essentially pushed out and
we only ever really saw him in one more
episode after that I would have loved to
have seen him play more of a reoccurring
role but I do believe that the actor
Corey nemec actually had some other
things going on and he eventually went
on to do some other shows after Stargate
so for him it probably wasn't too much
of a big deal but as as a viewer
watching it I fell in love with Jonas
Quinn and when he left I was actually
quite sad although I was very thankful
at the same time because Daniel Jackson
was fantastic I would have liked to see
Jonas Quinn a little bit more but why
did Michael Shanks leave in the first
place
well according to reports essentially
Michael Shanks didn't really feel like
Daniel Jackson the character was being
pushed to his limits he wasn't being
utilized as well as he maybe could have
been and he felt that the character was
kind of stagnating he wasn't moving on
with characters like tilk we we see the
story arc and we see their characters
evolve tilk was essentially a slave he
was first branch of office and he led
the Jafar rebellion and eventually
created the fridge of our nation so we
saw that Arc play out over the course of
10 seasons with Michael Shanks with
Daniel Jackson his story arc kind of
came to a close his initial story arc
was that he wanted to find his wife
charay the woman that he met and married
on abidos who was taken as a host by
amunet his entire Mission his entire
core purpose was to find and free and
hopefully live a life again with Charo
now ultimately that didn't happen Chari
and amuna and up being killed by tilk
and after that it kind of made Daniel
Jackson's story arc irrelevant it was
over it was done
that was until the harshis's child
storyline came in which was the child
born from apophisina munet which is the
genetic offspring of those two human
hosts but with the knowledge of all the
goal that came before it they had the
genetic memory now that played out
up until about season four when we saw
the the really we saw the final
incarnation of that in ultimate power
and I think it's this reason that
Michael Shanks decided that his
storyline was done and he wasn't being
pushed as far as he could have been now
there are many reports basically saying
that Michael Shanks didn't like how the
writers were writing his character and
basically didn't like the style that
they were going with him but he has come
out and said that that wasn't true so I
don't think that for any minute Michael
Shanks had any ill intentions towards
the people who were writing his
character or to anyone like Brad Wright
or anything like that but he ultimately
decided to leave the show and in season
five when he ascended he had for all
intents and purposes left he did appear
a few times in season six and right at
the end of season six he returned fully
but in that in between stage he wasn't
part of the show going back to what I
mentioned about Jonas Quinn basically
replacing Daniel Jackson and having
Daniel Jackson Leave the show a lot of
fans were understandably quite angry
quite annoyed that Daniel Jackson had
died and they were very vocal about it
Michael Shanks has been reported as
saying that he didn't realize how
how important the character of Daniel
Jackson was to the people who enjoy
Stargate and it's one of them things
isn't it you don't understand your true
worth until people start telling you for
me Daniel Jackson has always been
heart of Stargate when Stargate returns
because I honestly believe it will if
he's not in it in any way it's not going
to be Stargate as we know it because he
is the heart and soul as I've just said
he's the heart and soul he is the
basically the reason why the Stargate
project even got a green lit in the
first place back in the 1994 movie he is
the one who deciphered the symbols and
basically figured out the address to
aberdos which is which led them to go to
aberdos defeat ra and that's where he
met his wife and that's what created his
initial story arc in the first four
seasons also but beyond that Beyond
actually helping to found the Stargate
program
he was also the voice of reason for many
people he wasn't part of the military he
was a civilian so therefore he could
basically say whatever he wanted and he
always thought with his heart the
character of Daniel Jackson really just
wanted to discover new things he yearned
for knowledge he wanted to figure out
ancient languages and he really wanted
to help people in other cultures he was
a humanitarian of sorts and for me I
think Daniel Jackson was that that kind
of character that the audience latches
on to the one that we can relate to
because he is a civilian just going
along for the ride for all intents and
purposes
he is the one that we we feel the most
for we want to see him succeed we want
to see what happens with we want to see
what happens with the rest of the team
of course we do but Daniel Jackson was
that vehicle for the audience and when
he left it kind of made it a little bit
like that vehicle had gone and Jonah
Jonas Quinn was a fantastic replacement
I've said before he was a fantastic
character I absolutely loved him but
because we we were so used to Daniel
Jackson
for the first four or five seasons
having him not be there for season six
it was a bit of an adjustment and the
audience didn't really adjust
as great as Jonas Quinn was we wanted
Daniel Jackson back and thankfully the
writers and Michael Shanks got together
and they basically wrote him back into
the show by by descending him back down
to the human plane of existence and
honestly it's one of those things
where we got more out of it than what we
what what we thought basically Michael
shanks's character Daniel Jackson's
character rather went on to do better
and better things he became more more
vital to the to the to the team it was
much more action-oriented he became more
of an Indiana Jones kind of
archaeologist you know with a P90 and he
was more like
gung-ho kind of thing and it was more
interesting as a character so even
though he left for that for that year
essentially I think it was a good thing
for Stargate as a whole because of the
character that we got out of it and
Daniel Jackson has always been and
probably always will be one of my
favorite characters in Stargate My
ultimate favorite is tilk always has
been always will be but Daniel Jackson
is probably up there as well probably my
second favorite character of all time
what do you think let me know in the
comment section down below if you are
new to the YouTube channel make sure you
hit subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker by pressing the join button down
below
thank you so much for watching
I'll see you next week
[Music]